[Music]
choose wisely news oh is it the Netflix
uh uh uh black mayor oh yeah have you
guys seen it no that's why I said I need
to know I didn't answer I thought the
world revolved around every option oh
yeah here we go
submitted by no way Jose have you tried
all the options yes the
choose-your-own-adventure
publisher is suing Netflix over black
mirrors Bandersnatch what I heard about
this they're out of their minds
what's choose-your-own-adventure what is
that books or books where you choose so
like the 90s or the 80s and honestly
they saw it this is a choose your own
adventure books like they have all these
different types of books boring kinda it
sounds like if you want them to go to
the cave go here go to do that like we
would have choose your own that's the
first time I ever saw that actually a
thrid totally sketch where you could do
your tutor your own adventure thing with
the annotation remember that you choose
in indeed we did some sick ones we did
the Valentine's Day ones that were sick
yeah those went on forever yeah how do
you even like each thing and they wrote
it just to be basically genius so well
you and it appears so you [ __ ] up
something genius genius telling him what
to eat to knock your kidney stones cuz
he is a genius my great like hey you
know what's funny Bart's a genius do not
it's funny big Dumbo that is a big Dumbo
he says he's a genius no long record he
says all the time
you say you're a genius you're a
self-described Jesus like Kanye no I
still have a big Dumbo on record take a
shot every time bar says Dumbo that's
another deadly challenge I'm a big scam
bow alright damn bow danbo he's like
alright well
curious and since you haven't seen
Bandersnatch you could see these are all
the possible endings and the way the
story progresses there's one of us one
of the flowcharts that people leave oh
my god people may be some [ __ ] nerds
out there
we should go kick their ass I wanna know
how to write it that's how you write it
yeah after I saw that I was like oh yeah
so this whole thing is um it is similar
it is something I guess I you're not
that impressed then it's not genius work
right I'm very impressed
no one could ever do that Wow but yes I
felt like a single woman to me I am
today
oh [ __ ] we're fighting still so there's
this small Vermont publisher called
choose a co ll that sounds Japanese at
[ __ ] oh sorry
choose coke I love it when you [ __ ]
choose company it's just funny yeah
so this publisher they they have been
publishing interactive books since the
70s and so they have a federal trademark
registered trademark for the words
choose-your-own-adventure
and they actually say that in founders
neck oh that's why they're suing because
they're saying like you know like their
customers choose coast customers might
be confused that they are somehow
related to Bandersnatch and in bandar
sastras there's just so much bad in
there like Bruce is very like it's drug
use murder violent fighting mutilation
of a corpse the decapitation they're
white they have to say it in there
that's where they [ __ ] that they
probably didn't know but everybody
thinks some choose your own adventure
books when they think of like alternate
ways that you can choose the endings you
know it's almost like Kleenex now maybe
they didn't know that I wouldn't even
know I don't even know about your own
adventure you didn't hey I told you the
only time I had ever
heard of that was due to Lee Scott I
never knew that there were books oh
really
I had those books when I was a kid yeah
I look I read through all of them I
stood for sure there were some boring
tomes I was not unknown well did you
like reading in general yeah I loved
reading oh you did yeah yeah so now
they're suing that suing Netflix for 25
million dollars or Netflix is profits
from vendors net all the profit Geoffrey
is greater when yours irrelevant as them
right now this is their one shot you got
to shoot your shot you have to
mom-and-pop mom-and-pop think they only
have like seven employees I kind of suck
oh sure Netflix is getting sad left and
right dude
this is like probably the third one I've
heard also be getting sued for well they
got sued for the Sabrina oh yeah the
temple using the guy what a big temple
thing and then they're getting sued for
they use like trained footage and was
was a the bird box thing was that on
Netflix yeah mm-hmm so I think their
Netflix is also getting sued because
they used like real live train or some
like train footage of an accident like
on a TV in the background and like this
the town where that actual accident
happened is pissed
no how do you even recognize that [ __ ]
cuz you know Netflix is worth billions
that's how that's why because they're
getting sued that's why they freakin up
their prices then like now this lawsuit
is costing us all an extra $2.00 a month
costing all of it um what's the price
now thirteen fifteen right now it's
thirteen but I think it's gonna go up to
fifteen or six damn I didn't even know
that I don't even check they just
automatically charge it yeah I don't
either I don't really care in a few
months it'll take it it's like having a
water bill now somebody looked it was
like eight dollars but I have a list of
them that was years ago
yeah I just found out because of the
headlines I learned I'm no neither but
you guys should watch benders next week
well I mean it was alright oh yeah
you're - it's not it's not as amazing
yet yeah cuz I felt like cool I'm
strapped in for this ride later I'll do
it and then they started giving you all
these options and I'm like alright cool
I want to see how the movie progresses
with this option and then it keeps going
and then out of nowhere it's just a dead
end I'm like
there's a lot of done it well that's how
you write those things that's kind of a
holding it is it's how you get people to
go back and watch all of it so they get
more views so it seems I get it but I
just felt really unsatisfying for me I
didn't get to stop the story and then
restart yeah yeah because that is part
of the problem with that I think but
you're not going back to that far it'll
only take you back like to the last
option that you [ __ ] up on yeah so I
computed that is the one they wanted you
to it'll cycle you back and it's only
you only way so a couple minutes I may
need to choose the other one and keep
but it's almost like going a movie has
an intermission it's still stopping that
momentum it's just weird
it's just a weird thing when you're
watching something so I get I've always
understood that counterpoint to it so
yeah I liked it I enjoyed it I know that
the story itself like in all of its
endings really isn't like amazing
content but I still really enjoy like
back mirror man me and Nicky [ __ ] up I
like about 50% of them yeah season three
was the best yeah it was really good
thing I loved about 80% of them Wow I
would say 82 I just loved how they can
come up with these concepts where he's
just like yeah right the world it was
like that it's like toilet zone it's
like predictable at this point though
cuz it's always like oh he's in a
simulation or yeah I mean you kind of
see it coming down after this mini
season in my opinion that on Ostrom it's
always technology base and hell yeah
manatees evolves with technology mm-hmm
so it's a black mirror like when you
start your phone and snot on the block
here oh we should turn this video into a
choose your own choose your own would
you like to hear Steve and Nicky talk
about [ __ ] you should know you know I'm
saying talk about their marriage click
click here thumbs up right if not thumbs
down oh no no you just click to go that
direction and then Nicky's like one
there it sounds like Noah's better sorry
and it's like Oh would you like to see
would you like to follow Barton geo
today as they head home to see Tiger
right I think everyone wants yeah it's
basically leading everyone to our
channels or separate Channel
Haitians anymore like over here and you
could hang with Julia be honey can't you
gotta click all the way over here
what RV would ours be and Justin Tiff's
are just gonna they're gonna walk
they're gonna chose boobs and light
we've already done that's the right
they're gonna make out no don't play coy
because it's really boring I'm sorry
don't click it don't do it very one you
wanna hang the marriage part yeah yeah
we wanna watch a baby baby in a marriage
you know what Martin Gio so you get to
see their whole commute
our whole home yeah you get where it's
gonna explain a lot of stuff that's very
LGBT friendly not that good you guys
kiss weird just can't use make out weird
with it I've seen their boobs they're
not all that so just click and all that
click on there yeah click over here me
and Nikki gonna talk about our current
tax situation right vaginas tight dicks
over here oh we just got the monetize
you it'sa gorged that's a good dick if
the skins type that hard though I like
it to be a 90% hardness what yes what it
has to be a heart in the middle with a
little bit of soft skin on the out I
guess your acceptable not poppy
no not poppy 90 per you're ok with it a
- dick Miami personal you're telling me
that a dicks too hard and you're like oh
this is too hard Yeah right
[ __ ] Wiggly ass Asian yeah and there's
just you go like down a little bit and
you like they're softer the skin contact
from that to inside is much better it's
more friction kind of like it's kind of
like the skin feels better so great then
what's the hardest it hits the g-spot
yes no she knows yeah that's my [ __ ]
90% I'm not talking about 50% yeah I
don't want to a minor
Jess I wanna eight-plus quietly I wanna
a - do some extra credit I need 110 well
I'm happy you know I just bits like
pulsing it so that's what do you inject
cocaine into my dear
[Music]